Hi and welcome to Inferential Statistics. This course builds
on the skills you previously learned in Descriptive Statistics. Now
if you haven't taken Descriptive Stats yet, feel free
to follow the link in the instructor's notes box to
our descriptive stats class. Statistician John Tukey said an
approximate answer to the right problem is worth a good
deal more than the exact answer to an approximate problem.
Now in this course you will learn to apply statistics
to find these approximate answers, make predictions about data, as well as
run tests to verify the accuracy of a model. And for your
final project, you will get the chance to make your own predictions
on a data set. So, let's go to Katie Kormanik to get started